Esa no es la primera vez Obviamente el
General José insalam es la máxima figura
los guardias revolucionarios pero no es
la primera vez que desde esta
institución y de otras instituciones de
la república islámica se da por sentado
que las protestas no van a seguir
existiendo en el mismo momento que él
daba esas declaraciones en la ciudad de
chiradas en el sur occidente del país en
ese funeral en el cual se conmemoraba y
se recordaba a esas 15 personas
fallecidas en el atentado proclamado por
Isis el pasado miércoles a esta misma
hora se llevaban a cabo protestas no
solamente en varias universidades de
Teherán sino en otras ciudades más
pequeñas del país y esto se daba por
diferentes motivos porque habían sido
atacado los médicos en algunas
universidades porque los estudiantes no
creen la versión de la República
islámica de que el atentado en chiras
haya sido llevado por el estado islámico
discurso incluso acusan a las mismas
autoridades o también en algunos
funerales de personas que murieron
durante el fin de semana Así que hay que
esperar es muy probable que todos se
termine con esta proclamación de del
General salami pero habrá que verlo las
próximas días
Por supuesto continuaremos muy
pendientes de esto Catalina Pero por
otro lado las autoridades de la
República islámica acusaron hoy también
a las periodistas que revelaron la
muerte de amini y que cubrieron a su
funeral momento en que empezaron las
protestas de haber sido entrenadas por
la Cia porque esta nueva acusación de
injerencia extranjera Y qué se sabe del
estado de las periodistas
la República islámica ha acusado a
Estados Unidos a lo que llaman el estado
sionista a Gran Bretaña y Arabia Saudita
está detrás de estas protestas sino
solamente estar detrás sino estar
promocionando Muchos medios que operan
desde el extranjero en lengua persa y
que estarían también según ellos
motivando estas protestas estas dos
periodistas son bastante reconocidas en
el país es dedicadas a temas sociales y
ella se dedicaron no solamente a contar
la historia de masa a mí el día que fue
llevada a la clínica sino también en el
Jam estuvo en la ciudad donde fue
enterrada y son reconocidísimas hasta el
punto que muchos periodistas dicen hoy
que ellas no necesitan ser entrenadas
por ninguna fuerza de seguridad
extranjera para saber cuál es su trabajo
y esta preocupación de estas acusaciones
son bastante graves porque la hacen
conjuntamente tanto el Ministerio de
inteligencia como el departamento de
inteligencia de los guardias
revolucionarios que generalmente no
suelen trabajar juntos Así que preocupa
la seguridad de estas mujeres que
bienvenidas están en la cárcel por
muchos días estuvieron en Solitarios en
sus celdas han podido llamar a sus
esposos pero al día de hoy no han tenido
ningún juicio y no se sabe realmente de
que las acusan